boy this is pretty cool you and me at
the academy award this is insane dude
look at all this talent all this talent
in one spot there's this Daniel
day-lewis
there's alan arkin there's joaquin
phoenix and you know what's interesting
all those actors i just named a pot
jewish oh okay what about you you got a
you got a Berg on the endian am i yeah
you are you Jewish
am i Jewish no actually I'm Catholic
wrong answer try again what look you
want to work in this town don't you oh
that that's interesting Mac because I am
Jewish no you're not I am I am I was
born Fyodor Shapiro and I would like to
donate money to Israel and continue to
work in Hollywood forever thank you I am
Jewish you're an idiot
yeah well we'll see who the idiot is
when they give me my private plane at
the next secret synagogue meeting I'm
not doing a sequel with you okay and the
nominees for best sound editing are I go
Erik a doll and Ethan vandal and Django
Unchained while e-statement Life of Pi
Eugene ganti and Philip Stockton Skyfall
here
zero dark thirty ball NJ Madison and the
Oscar goes to we have a tie no BS we
have a tie the first Oscar goes to zero
dark thirty
to the Academy Thank You this is such an
such an honor
Catherine what a fantastic movie and and
my crew yeah I was fortunate be here a
few years ago for Mukul heart Locker and
I was awarded two of these I woke up in
the morning 7 o'clock where our son is
that one for mommy
one of her dad he looked at and said
where's mine and feel I love you Karen I
love you mom watching at home I love you
and my dad there but God now I love you
I miss you goodnight thank you
and the second Oscar goes to
Skyfall Karen Baker Lander
category for the
well thank you the Academy this is so
cool
well we wished we could work on a Bond
movie and we never quite thought that
was going to happen but it did and we
just want to thank Michael and Barbara
for inviting us to the family then we
we've got Sam Mendes as the director and
not just made it even sweeter we got to
mix where our friends Scott and Greg and
now this and I just want to say that all
the other nominees in this category
world storytellers we just tell our
story through sound and this is a huge
honor is tell me to wrap it up now I
want to thank Peter stably Dino demure
Oh Chrissa cells dan Hegeman Chris Hogan
Stu ver and our guys Tony and Phil Chris
star go Chris Charlotte Craig Yeager
thank you so much